le maître verrier et dire oh mais nous
reçoit dans son atelier du centre
d'orléans où il s'est installé il ya
cinq ans il est en train de restaurer un
vitrail en provenance d'un château du
loir et là je rassemble mes pièces sur
mon vitrail et là je fais comme un grand
p veulent cet été à l'instar des lieux
chargés d'histoire et 10 ouvre les
portes de son atelier aux touristes pour
qu'ils découvrent son savoir faire
on en reste clic le démontage du vitrail
le dessin la peinture sur verre parce
que chaque vitrail on peut avoir un
vitrail cas des verres de couleur et
après on pas avoir un vitrée avec de la
peinture sur verre or là la peinture
serveurs nan nan toute une technique et
c'est là que ça dure beaucoup plus
longtemps
si pendant le confinement le maître
verrier a continué à travailler
aujourd'hui son carnet de commandes est
plus incertain une situation qui touche
l'ensemble des artisans d'art de la
région très souvent leur seul débouché
on va dire effectivement économique ou
leurs seules ventes se font à travers
des expositions des festivals ou des
ouvertures d'ateliers
tout cela bien évidemment avec la crise
de l'aco vide a été stoppée et donc ils
subissent si vous voulez actuellement
est bien des pertes de chiffres
d'affaires monumental c'est pour ça que
nous avons voulu dans le cadre de cette
saison estivale dans le cadre du
tourisme
bien évidemment mettre aussi en valeur
ses métiers d'art parce que c'est une
occasion d'aller les voir
maître verrier ébéniste tailleur de
pierres et même styliste 1500 métiers
d'art nous tendent les bras durant tout
l'été
l'occasion de faire vivre le made in
france et de donner un coup de pouce à
l'économie de proximité